hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast investigating the locust
of conscience sensory experience in the
brain
presented by brian odin guard
postdoctoral research scientist
university of since university of
california los angeles i am christina
mahalik of lab roots and I'll be your
moderator for today's event we are
delighted to bring you this educational
web seminar presented by labrys laborat
is the leading scientific social
networking website and producer of
educational virtual events and webinars
before we begin I like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at anytime you want during the
presentation just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box that appears on the
screen we will answer as many questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the help desk button located in the
promotional board at the bottom center
of your screen or use the ask a question
box to let us know you're having a
problem this presentation is educational
and most offers continuing education
credits please click on the consuming
education credits tab located in the top
right corner of the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
Odegard I will now turn the presentation
over to him
fantastic Kristina thank you so much for
that wonderful introduction Thanks to
everyone at lab roots for helping
organize this event and thanks to all of
you online for taking the time to listen
today so as you just heard my name is
Brian
Odegard and I currently work as a post
doctoral researcher in the consciousness
and metacognition laboratory at UC
and I also have a secondary affiliation
in the Department of decoded
neurofeedback at the advanced
telecommunications Research Institute
international in Kyoto Japan and as you
can see from this title slide what I'm
going to talk about today are
experiments that I've been doing over
the past three years to try to
investigate which parts of the brain
help facilitate our capacity for
conscious sensory experience so in
general as a researcher my overall goal
has been to better understand the neural
physiology and the computational
principles that are in play when we look
at scenes like this one that you see on
the screen and we have a sensory
experience
so I actually snapped this photo when I
was back in Tokyo in November this is
the Shibuya station where I came out
after coming out from the airport to try
to see some friends in Tokyo and I
thought this scene really captures how
incredible our brains are at processing
so many different pieces of visual
information all at once so you can see
here in this scene of nightlife that
there are so many colors and shapes and
things happening all at once and it's
really a remarkable capacity that we
possess to actually process this scene
coherently all at the same time and to
understand what it is that we're seeing
so I'm after a more mechanistic
understanding of what the brain is
actually doing to facilitate our
experiences of sensory phenomenology
it's called our experience of what it
actually feels like to experience this
visual scene in the moment now this is a
question that researchers have been
wrestling with for decades in terms of
trying to understand which parts of the
brain actually facilitate this capacity
that we have and many researchers for
the past few decades have talked about
how when we think about vision there are
well-established findings in the field
that show that what's called the ventral
stream is necessary for coding certain
visual features that we experience so as
you can see in this image if you look at
the back parts of the brain the
posterior areas that are labeled v1 and
v2
many neuro scientific investigations
that show that these parts the brain
help code for fairly simple visual
features so neurons in these areas might
be coding for like lines of different
orientations as you can see in the
images or possibly more complex shapes
as you can see in areas like v4 or even
parts of the temporal lobe and we think
that there is a chain of processing a
hierarchy involved where as we move up
this chain more and more complex
features are encoded by these visual
areas so a lot of evidence indicates
that these posterior parts of the cortex
code for visual contents neurons in
these regions help facilitate encoding
of visual information and many
researchers subscribe to a school of
thought that says okay we know that
posterior areas are involved in visual
processing but then when we think about
what the front parts of the brain are
doing so as you can see in this image we
have parts labeled F R for the frontal
regions and P AR which is actually
labeling parts of the parietal lobe it's
called we can typically think of these
areas in the brain as being responsible
to in facilitating our capacity to
report what it is that we're
experiencing so some researchers
subscribe to this idea that there's a
dichotomy between posterior areas that
code for the visual things we see and
then parts of the brain that help us
actually speak or report what it is that
we're experiencing in a given moment so
this idea has been around for a number
of years and it's actually seen renewed
vigor and interest in some recent
articles from the past few years like
the one that I'm showing here so this
comes from this image that I'm showing
comes from an article by Melanie Foley
marchello masam II now Tsuchiya Brad
coastal Kristoff [ __ ] and Giulio Tononi
these people are fantastic scientists
that have been leaders in the field to
try to talk about what conscious
experience is and how the brain might
facilitate our capacity for it and this
image actually represents this view
point that I was just discussing quite
well where if you look at all of the
parts that are shown in red in this
schematic
brain these research researchers say
that this is really the part of the
brain that enables what's called the
full neural correlates of consciousness
so you can see that acronym on the slide
it says full NCC off to the right side
and it's this idea that again it's
primarily posterior areas that help
facilitate our ability to experience the
sensory world when we're out and moving
about and then you can see with these
areas that are shown in black which are
the front parts of the brain these areas
help us do different things but they're
not directly involved in what it is we
mean when we say that that we're looking
for the areas that encode conscious
content so if you take a look at those
black areas towards the left side of the
slide there are a few highlighted in
different colors so you can see one of
these blue areas you can see it's
important for verbal report so we know
that there are some parts of the frontal
lobe that facilitate our capacity for
language again being able to speak about
what it is that we see in a given moment
you can see the area that's colored in
beige in this slide and they refer to
this part as being involved in
processing loops so there's an acronym
there that's called DL PFC and that
acronym stands for the dorsal lateral
prefrontal cortex and they say that this
part of the brain is very important for
processes like attention and working
memory so if we're looking out at the
visual world and we want to selectively
attend to certain objects like maybe we
want to pay attention to a few people or
maybe there's an animal that's moving
the frontal part of the brain helps us
actually select which things we want to
selectively
attend to in the given moment but the
content would be distinct from this
process of attention but we know that
this area that's shown in beige they say
is also involved in working memory so if
you want to try to store items from say
a phone number that you've just heard
through your auditory system this
frontal part of the brain would help you
keep in mind the digits for that phone
number for some duration of time and
then finally you can see in another blue
region in the frontal part of the brain
it's labeled m1 this part of the brain
is important for motor report so say
you're a scientist and you want to study
what people are consciously
experiencing in a given moment well one
of the best ways we have to do that is
simply to ask people what it is they are
experiencing a given moment and what
usually experimenters we try to have
people push buttons to report what it is
that they're experiencing we sometimes
ask for verbal reports we also ask for
button pushes and according to this
group it's this region of primary motor
cortex and a few other areas added in
that help people execute these commands
to actually report what it is they're
experiencing so overall this image of
the brain is trying to show us that
according to this view we have posterior
areas that help code for content and
then parts of the frontal lobe that help
code for things like attention and our
capacity to report what it is that we
experience okay so with that view in
mind part of the goal I have for today
is to challenge that view one of the
things that I do as a researcher is to
try to study how high-level processes in
the brain a high-level perceptual
decision-making circuitry that we might
think of as being dissociated from these
questions about sensory awareness and
consciousness these circuits and these
processes actually play integral roles
in facilitating our conscious experience
of the sensory world so as an
investigator there are a few different
processes that I'm interested in that
are sometimes written off as being
what's called post perceptual or maybe
high level and being disconnected from
sensory experience and what I'm going to
argue today is that some of these
processes play an integral role in
facilitating sensory experience itself
okay so what are some of these processes
that I'm referencing here well one of
them is the sense of confidence so if
right now you're looking at me or you
stare around the room that you're in you
can think about experiencing different
aspects of the visual world with a
different amounts of certainty but even
though you have different amounts of
certainty I'm gonna argue that with
whatever visual experience is it
inherently involves some degree of
confidence in the things that we see so
confidence or the capacity for Medicom
is a topic that people often attribute
to what I mentioned before is being part
of post perceptual processing but I'm
going to show you some experiments I've
run today that challenge this viewpoint
and I'll argue for a different
perspective that whenever you experience
the visual world your capacity to have a
sense of confidence in what you see or
to metacognitive metacognitively reflect
on what you see plays an integral part
and experience itself I'm also pretty
interested in perceptual decisions and
my interest in perceptual decisions
comes in investigating what peripheral
vision is doing at any given moment so
most of your visual field if you think
about what you can see outside of the
region that you're looking at right at
this moment it's characterized by this
sort of ambiguity you feel like you
experience the surround of the visual
field in a high degree of detail but we
know in a number of experiments in
carefully controlled environments that
you don't actually see the periphery
quite as well as you think you do
so part of my research uses a technique
an investigative area called
psychophysics to try to characterize
what peripheral vision is doing and how
your perceptual system helps facilitate
decision-making about what it is that
you see so I'm going to argue in a few
studies that I'll cover today you think
you see the periphery better than you
really do and once we actually use
carefully controlled methods to figure
out what's going on we can actually see
how the brain tends to inflate our sense
of the periphery so you think you see
more than you actually do but we need
experiments to tease this apart to
really understand what's going on with
that aspect of conscious sensory
experience and then the other two things
I'll cover today I've done some work on
perceptual integration so one of the
things that marks your conscious sensory
experience of the world is the fact that
it's coherence you have so many brain
regions that are dealing with processing
different pieces of sensory information
at any given point in time and yet
what's remarkable about your experience
as you're watching this presentation as
you're listening to me speak is that
experience is coherent you don't have
the sense that things are disjoint and
scale
I'll talk about more of what integration
means later on but I'm very interested
in and trying to investigate which parts
of the brain facilitate this capacity
for coherent sensory experience in the
world and then I'm going to wrap up
today by talking about perceptual
content so I also open this talk saying
that we think that posterior areas play
a critical role in encoding content
those parts of visual cortex that I
mentioned before I'm actually really
interested in how prefrontal areas might
be encoding perceptual content so I'll
talk some about work that I've done in
Japan at my secondary affiliation at ATR
to try to investigate how frontal
regions of the brain might be encoding
the contents of your experience and see
if we can try to come to a new
understanding of which parts of the
brain you really need to be conscious so
let's dig in that was a long
introduction but hopefully you see the
roadmap now for where I want to go and
we can start talking about some of these
experiments and some of the data to
learn things along the way so I want to
start today by talking about confidence
because as I mentioned before I really
think that having some sense of
confidence in what it is that you've
seen facilitates your capacity for what
are called perceptual qualia this idea
that if you're looking at this image
that I'm showing on the slide you can
see that's outside Shibuya station
there's a forever21 sign that's lit up
and it's sort of a bluish purplish color
you can see some of the other Japanese
writing on other signs and again if you
look at that you inherently have some
degree of confidence in what it is that
you're seeing and this has been an area
of active investigation
for a few decades now using non-human
primates so the research groups that
have really been pioneers and trying to
understand which parts of the brain
facilitate our capacity for perceptual
confidence have often been studying this
in regions that are involved in what's
called the oculomotor circuit so you can
see here there's a picture of a brain
and we have a picture of an eyeball on
the left side and you can see that the
eyeball is feeding information in to a
part of the thalamus called the LGN
and that one this actually connects to
many different areas in cortex but we
think that there are a few different
regions that are involved in control of
how we move our eyes that's what this
circuit is showing here that also might
encode our sense of perceptual
confidence so whenever we talk about
brain regions we always use usual
abbreviations and acronyms and some of
the areas that have been implicated in
these parts of the brain that help us
move our eyes some of these regions that
have been implicated in confidence are
the lateral intraparietal area that's
called Li P shown near the top of the
slide and also what are called the
frontal eye fields so some people that
have studied eye movements in this area
I think there's also a neural signature
that encodes our sense of confidence and
what it is that we've seen but recently
I've been in collaboration with other
researchers at UCLA to try to study this
area that's shown towards the bottom so
it's abbreviated SC and this is called
the superior colliculus so again
traditionally the superior colliculus is
a region that we know is actively
involved in controlling how we move our
eyes to different locations across the
visual field there's also some research
that shows that the Spear colliculus is
involved in how we integrate
audio-visual information but we've
launched a new investigation to see
whether or not the superior colliculus
also helps encode our sense of
confidence in what it is that we've seen
and this is in collaboration with a few
people from Michelle Bastos lab at UCLA
that specializes in these types of
experiments so in total here we can see
the oculomotor circuit we think there
are a few different areas involved in
confidence but we're going to focus on
the SC this region towards the bottom
here okay so in the first experiment
that we launched the way that people
often investigate confidence in
non-human primates is with what's called
a dot motion test so the test that we
used actually involves two components
which I'll explain here on this slide so
if you look at the top row what we have
trained rhesus macaques to do in this
task is to first fixate on a central
point so
we're gonna stare at a red dot and then
what we will do is we'll show them an
array of moving dots so you'll see in
the top row in that third panel there
are a bunch of white dots shown on the
slide and what this is represented is a
brief stimulus that we show the monkeys
where most of these dots are moving in
completely random directions but a
certain percentage are all moving in one
coherent direction in this example
they'd either be moving to the left or
to the right so we show this stimulus
for a brief period of time and then
there's a delay period where the macaque
keeps fixating and then afterwards when
the fixation dot disappears so you can
see that red dot goes missing in the
last panel that's when the macaque has a
cue to make a choice by making an eye
movement either to the right or the left
depending on which direction they
thought the dots were primarily moving
so we trained monkeys to do this they
stare at a fixation cross they see a
bunch of dots most of which are randomly
moving at some are moving in a coherent
direction and then the macaque makes a
choice about which direction they think
had the dominant motion to the right or
to the left so you can see in these in a
top row they have to make a choice to
either target towards the right or a
target towards the left to report the
direction of motion they perceived but
in the bottom row we also have other
trials they're called in this experiment
where there's a twist and you can see in
the bottom row we have a few other
targets that are on the screen you can
see one is a green dot and then there's
another gray dot so on these trials that
include this green dot at the bottom
what the macaques can actually do is if
they see these dots moving and they're
not sure which way the primary dot
motion direction was going if they're
not sure if it was to the right or to
the left these macaques can actually on
these trials select this green option
for what's called an opt-out or sure
choice reward so what the monkeys are
trying to do here is they're trying to
actually earn juice rewards for
performing this task and on these trials
if the monkey sees something that it's
not sure of it can select this green
option for a smaller but guaranteed
reward so these trials are interesting
because of a cat can either choose to
report an answer and try to earn the
all reward or it can select this opt-out
option for the guaranteed but smaller
reward and we throw that fourth target
that I haven't mentioned yet the one
that's at the top in row B that is
simply to control for lateral
interactions between neurons so if the
macaque selects this target nothing
happens they're not actually supposed to
choose this one and they only choose it
on a small number of trials but really
we're interested in the difference
between trials where the macaque makes a
choice and trials from the CAC opt out
okay so with this paradigm in mind we
then go looking at the behavior to see
what this looks like when monkeys are
performing the task and what we have
seen is that if you look at this chart
on the left side on this slide we have
motion strength or the percent of
coherently moving dots shown on the
bottom axis and then on the y-axis here
we have the probability of making an
opt-out response so this is referring to
what percentage of trials does the
macaque actually select that green shirt
royce option and what this chart is
showing is that on trials that are
really difficult the macaque tends to
opt out much more often than trials
where it's much easier to tell which
direction the dots are moving so you can
see on trials that are easy where 50% of
those dots are moving in a coherent
direction the macaque so we opt out a
small percentage of the time but then on
trials that are either very difficult or
impossible in the zero-percent case the
macaques are much more likely to select
that opt-out response option for the
guaranteed sure choice reward so this is
good another experiment is working that
the monkeys are performing in the way
that we think they will be and then we
are also very interested in how the
difference between those two trial types
that I mentioned before on the previous
slide between row a and row B what it
looks like in terms of how well the
monkeys perform so what we're showing
here in panel D is how often the
macaques are correct for these different
motions drinks and then you can see
there's two different trial types that
we're plotting in panel d1 our trials
were the opt-out was available but wait
so the
solid gray circles our trials when that
green sure choice option was on the
screen but the monkey said no I know
what's going on I'm going to make an
answer choice and we're looking at the
difference there between trials where
the opt-out was available but waived
versus trials where the opt-out was
unavailable and the monkey was forced to
make a choice so what you can see here
is that on trials where the opt-out was
available but waived macaques tend to
get a higher percentage correct than on
trials where they have to make a choice
to the left or right so this is very
interesting because what this likely
means is that macaques are more
confident on those trials where the
opt-out is available but waived compared
to trials where they're less confident
often having a mix of high and low
confidence because they're forced to
make a choice so this is good very
interesting behavior and now we can
start asking questions about how neurons
might be encoding these differences or
facilitating this capacity so about a
decade ago there was pioneering work
done and I was published in the journal
Science by ruse Becky Ani and Mike
Shanin that used a similar opt-out dot
motion task and what they found was for
monkeys that are performing this opt-out
task they showed firing rate differences
for trials where the animal was making a
saccade towards the receptive field and
trials where the animal was making a
saccade away from the receptive field so
there are a few terms I just use that we
probably want to unpack to make sense of
what's going on that you can see what we
talked about making a saccade that's a
word for an eye movement and when we
talk about T in and T out these are
referring to trials where the monkey
makes an eye movement towards that
shaded gray area that's shown in this
panel and T out means the monkey is
selecting the option that's further away
from that shaded gray area in the image
so they first show that you can actually
look at firing rate differences on
correct trials between which target
monkey is selecting and what they showed
in this task that was very very
interesting was that on trials where
that sure choice option was waived so in
this example this would be where the
monkey chooses the blue dot the firing
rates of neurons in this part of the
brain were at an intermediate level
compared to what its elected the other
two options so you can see in panel D
here we have dotted lines that are in
between those two solid lines and what
the dotted lines are representing is
when the monkey selects that sure choice
or opt-out response so this is very
interesting because what we have here
are neural firing rate differences
between trials where the animal was
correct and selected one of those two
targets on the right or left that's the
solid black or the solid gray line and
we have those targets where the monkey
selected the opt-out shown by the dotted
lines so this was fascinating and people
this was purported to be a neural
signature of confidence so we wanted to
see whether or not we could find similar
neural signatures in the superior
colliculus this is that sub cortical
region that I showed you in the
oculomotor circuit about ten minutes ago
and what we were intrigued to see was
that the firing rate profiles of neurons
in the colliculus followed a very
similar I should say profile or style
compared to what you see in the Li P so
shown in this right-hand panel for our
neurons in the colliculus that we were
recording from you can see that when the
animal selects the opt-out shown by the
dotted lines in the image the firing
rates are kind of intermediate but when
the animal selects either of the
rewarded targets either the one towards
the receptive field shown by the black
solid line or the one going away from
the receptive field shown by the gray
solid line there are firing rate
differences between those things so this
was fascinating we have found another
region of the brain that looks like it
tracks how well animals are performing
but what we wanted to do was go above
and beyond these single-cell analyses
and we wanted to change the paradigm in
a few ways one is to clean up a
potential motor related confound so in
science we're always worried about
confounds alternative explanations for
what could count for the data that we're
seeing and we wanted to make sure that
we could get rid of motor related
confounds that might be present in this
paradigm we're dealing with the
oculomotor circuit and we want to talk
about confidence so how do we know that
things are actually tracking confidence
and not just motor behaviors we needed
we needed to clean that up and then we
also wanted to look at population level
activity so we know that there are
algorithms that do a very good job now
of trying to
analyze how populations of neurons
encode information and we wanted to try
applying some of these algorithms to see
if we could discover how the brain is
encoding confidence if at all in this
region so intriguing first results but
what we next did was we started to build
what are called neuronal decoders to try
to read out what the population of
neurons is doing which might be linked
to confidence so what we did we were
recording from V probe electrodes and
usually we recorded from around it was
around 824 neurons on any given day and
we could record the firing rates of all
of these neurons across time as the
animals did the tasks so to decode the
information what we would actually do is
take a sum of the spike counts in a
given time window and to build our
decoders we would slide this window
across time to read out the neural
information and what this gets us is a
sum of spike counts across time for each
of the neurons and we could try to
decode information across time to see if
we can read out signatures of confidence
so to link this to what I described
before what we really want to do here is
look at differences between trials
worthy where the opt-out was unavailable
and trials where the opt-out was
available but waived because we think
that the trials where it wasn't
available are marked by lower confidence
we forced the animal to make a choice
and trials where the opt-out is
available but waived are marked by
higher confidence because the animal
could have selected that sure choice
option but it didn't so we think this
comparison in this experiment would be
informative for trying to read out a
signature of confidence so again we want
to compare what I mentioned before were
target in and target out correct trials
as a function of opt out availability
following the logic that I just
described so again we're looking for a
neural signature that can distinguish
between those solid gray circles those
trials and what neurons are doing on the
trials where there are those white open
circles we want to see if we can read
out the difference in what neurons are
doing between those two trial types okay
and what did we see so what I'm going to
show here are results from our decoder
as we were trying to read out signatures
of confidence the first thing that we
did was we tried to decode what the
animal was going to do when the answer
choices popped up on the screen so
ideally if things are going the way we
think they are we would not be able to
decode what the animal is going to do in
the end until it's actually seeing the
dots supposedly as the animal sees the
dots presumably the neurons are going to
be encoding this information and the
animal will accumulate evidence and
eventually come to a decision with some
degree of confidence but we first wanted
to see whether or not we could predict
the choice that the animal was going to
make so to make sense of this plot I'm
going to show the y-axis here that's
labeled posterior probability we are
trying to actually predict whether or
not a given trial that we're trying to
decode involves a correct T in or T out
choice so the y-axis here is the
probability of predicting a correct T in
choice and to make sense of what we're
actually showing here you can see that
when the motion signals come on
something interesting happens so on
trials where the opt-out was available
but waived these are shown by the blue
lines and you can see that after the
animal starts seeing the dot motion and
it starts integrating evidence and
coming to a conclusion about what choice
is going to make then if we're decoding
from these neurons we can actually
predict the choice that the animal is
going to make so what we're showing here
in these blue lines is the neural firing
rate differences allow us to decode on a
given trial whether or not a T in or T
out choice is going to be made so these
blue lines are showing those trials
where the opt-out is available to wait
and you can see that the difference on
these trials where the opt-out is
available but waived is greater than the
trials where the opt-out is unavailable
so this comparison is very very
interesting we wanted to find a neural
signature of confidence and here we can
look at how neurons are integrating
information across time read out a
population level activity and you can
see that we have firing rate differences
in the population that are informative
we have differences between trials where
the opt-out is available but waived
shown in blue compared to when the
opt-out is unavailable and on the
right-hand side of this slide you can
see that by the time an animal makes a
saccade when it finally makes the choice
then we can decode with almost perfect
accuracy what's going to happen but it's
really this intermediate range in the
middle that's informative we see fire
and rate differences which seem to track
the differences between these trial
types okay so that's great um for most
circumstances we we know that typically
in the world as you are looking at
things you're how confident you are tend
to track how accurate you are so usually
if you're able to do a perceptual task
and do it well you're going to be more
and more confident but one confusion
that people often have is they often
think the confidence is the same thing
as the probability of how accurate you
are in a task and these things actually
dissociate in very interesting ways so
capitalizing on a paradigm that was
introduced in the psycho physics
literature a few years ago we wanted to
come up with a paradigm to dissociate
your sense of confidence from how well
you can perform the task because in
science we often want to try to isolate
these variables to find a true neural
signature of something so what wanted to
do in this second experiment is to come
up with a paradigm where the task
performance would be the same across two
conditions but we'd get different levels
of confidence in terms of the reports we
get from the mechanics so the way that
we did that shown in panel a is we used
our same motion task we're still going
to see stimuli with a bunch of randomly
moving dots but now we're going to
change the task just a little bit so
that we will compare conditions where
you have a lot of dots moving in the
coherent correct direction but then some
percentage of dots moving in the
incorrect direction so the task for the
monkeys here is still the report of the
dominant motion direction but what
they're going to have to do is they're
going to have to figure out what's going
on across two conditions where the ratio
of dots moving in the correct and
incorrect direction is the same and
what's very interesting about these two
conditions
is you can actually match task
performance shown in the light gray bars
in panel B so you can have roughly the
same percentage correct we'll say across
the two conditions but you can these
conditions produce different degrees of
confidence and indexed by that opt out
response how often they select the shirt
choice option so again here what we're
showing is between these two evidence
that we call low positive evidence and
high positive evidence you can see that
these dot motion ratios produce the same
level of performance but as shown by the
dark gray bars they opt out much more
often in one condition the low positive
evidence condition compared to the other
so this is interesting we have
conditions that now produce the same
level of accuracy with different degrees
of confidence so now we can go look in
the colliculus and see whether or not we
can find neural signals which track that
okay and what did we see well it was
interesting because the effects that we
saw in the first experiment went away so
when we looked at these differences
between T in and T out trials across
these two new conditions the high
positive evidence condition and the low
positive evidence condition so those are
the blue and the green lines
respectively we actually couldn't decode
the same differences between those two
conditions as we could in the first
experiment so you can still read in read
out T and versus T our differences but
there's nothing in the colliculus that
seems to distinguish between those two
conditions so that's a lot to digest in
terms of its relevance for the topic but
let me summarize here what we have
learned from these two experiments
so first conceptually it's a little bit
hard to wrap your mind around at first
but confidence is different from task
accuracy yes those two things normally
go hand in hand and people have been
saying that and coming up with
statistical frameworks to formulate that
in quantitative and rigorous ways like
the paper I'm citing here but these
really are two different things
and we can come up with clever paradigms
to try to exploit that to find the
neural signature confidence in the brain
we saw in the first experiment but the
colliculus encodes a form of confidence
that's similar to other parts of the
oculomotor circuit like li
so the colliculus tracks tasks accuracy
which is very interesting this is
something that we didn't know that it
could do effectively but we don't think
the colliculus encodes true subjective
confidence so in terms of trying to
identify the part of the brain that
facilitates our sense of confidence we
don't think that that true sense is in
the colliculus nor do we think it's in
some of these other regions that have
previously been reported as having the
neural correlates of confidence so what
this really has led to is a we've
surveyed the literature and we think we
have here a paradigm which others can
exploit to investigate further which
brain regions really encode that true
sense of confidence and we know from the
human neuroimaging literature that
prefrontal cortex is likely involved in
that process there are many many studies
that use what's called fMRI which show
that frontal parts of the brain activity
in those areas seems to be linked to our
sense of confidence and we're following
up on this study in the colliculus to
try to see if we can see that in this
investigation as well maybe neurons in
prefrontal areas will encode the true
sense of confidence since we've now been
able to rule out true subjective
confidence being in the colliculus or at
least we have no results that provides
evidence for that and we think these
results challenge the conception of it
being in other areas too okay so that's
a lot to digest that was actually the
biggest thing that I had to cover today
hopefully the rest of the topics will be
a little bit easier to cover so we've
looked at confidence we've challenged
some ideas about where that resides and
we know that there's some evidence
that's frontal areas but what about
perceptual decisions I mentioned
originally that my interest in
perceptual decisions comes mainly from
my interest in peripheral vision and
peripheral vision is weird so if we if
we look at what peripheral vision is
like there's this image I like from a
recent paper by Michael Cohen and Nancy
kanwisher and for those of you you might
know that named in philosophy Dan
Dennett he was an author on this paper
as well they've argued that when you
think about what peripheral vision is
like it's surprising we know that the
number of photoreceptors and the
resolution tails off out
what's called phobia the central region
of visual space but they note in this
paper that when you think about what
peripheral vision is like the world
doesn't fade to black
outside of where we're directly looking
it looks roughly like some sort of
smeared rough summary representation
like the panels that are shown on the
right hand side of this image so again
peripheral vision it doesn't all fade to
black there's some degree of resolution
there's some information that we have
but it also looks kind of smeary and
blurred and we it can be tough to
characterize what's going on so my work
has tried to build on some interesting
findings for the last few years about
what characterizes peripheral vision so
one of the findings that caught my eye
was a work by Guillermo solavei and a
few other co-authors that show that in
the periphery when we make judgments
about what it is that's in the periphery
we tend to have liberal response bias
ease so if we are looking at tasks where
you simply have to detect whether or not
say a simple visual grading was
presented we know that people tend to
report the grading being present much
more often than it actually was we tend
to have liberal detection biases outside
the center of our visual field so that's
what this chart is showing right here we
can measure response bias and show that
people tend to have liberal detection
biases in the periphery and this has
been shown in other work as well where
if we look at how people perform in
tasks where they are either attending or
not attending to certain regions
that's the queued and the uncute
conditions we know that in areas where
you're not attending these liberal
response biases shown by the parts
labeled see here they tend to show up so
if you're not attending or if it's in
the periphery you tend to think you see
things even when they aren't there and
I've started some collaborations I have
a fantastic co-authors names mucin Lee
from Tsinghua University in China and
Newson has coated up new tasks in
driving simulations so he actually has
coated some things that look like
virtual reality and we've conducted
experiments where people drive down
suburban roads and we asked them what
they actually see in the periphery as
they come up to stoplights and we ask
that
about the color of pedestrians clothing
so as people do these tasks and we have
them make judgments about people that
are presented in the periphery of their
visual field in the simulated driving
environment and we simply ask them
whether or not the person was wearing a
yellow shirt in the experiment I'm going
to show results from right now and what
we've seen in the data is something
interesting where let's just look at
panel B here for the sake of simplicity
on trials where people are attending to
the location that will ask about where
I'm going to ask you whether or not a
person was wearing a yellow shirt and in
the valid condition that's shown in
panel B you know that ahead of time you
know where the person is going to show
up or you'll have to make a shirt
related judgement what we have shown is
that people are pretty accurate in that
condition where you're attending to
where you should be but if we compare
that to conditions where you're not
attending that's the invalid bar that's
shown in white right here you actually
have more liberal response biases so in
this experiment you are much more likely
to say yes someone with a yellow shirt
was there even when they worked so we
also have seen in these naturalistic
environments that you tend to be more
prone to false alarms that are called
you're tend to you tend to say that you
think you saw things that weren't
actually there and that's pretty
interesting we've also done this with
more complex stimuli so I have started
using Amazon editor to try to bring
visual experiments to the masses
recently online and I run some tasks
where I have people look at a briefly
flashed grid of lights of different
orientations and in one an online
experiment that I run I flashed these
lines either in the center of their
computer screen or in the periphery and
I simply asked people was there a group
of lines that were all tilted in the
same direction so there's going to flash
some lines tell me whether or not there
was a group of lines that are all tilted
in the same way and then tell me how
confident you are in that response and
what we've seen in this type of task is
that shown on the left-hand side here
people tend to be slightly better doing
this task at the center compared to the
periphery so that's not surprising right
when we
try to make visual judgments we would
expect to be better when we're doing it
right where we're looking compared to
doing it off to the side of our visual
field but what's interesting again is
that even though you're worse doing this
task in the periphery you can see in the
dark shaded bars on the right hand side
you once again may have a more liberal
bias to say that yes there were coherent
lines there even when they weren't so
again yes you're worse in the edges of
the visual field that we would expect
but if I look at the way that you're
wrong you're often saying that yes that
thing was present even when it wasn't
and we've seen this phenomenon show up
in other ways so some of our
collaborators at Hong Kong including a
single excuse me uh Singh Hank Chung and
also menu Chang they conducted an
investigation using a phenomenon called
crowding so you can see in this
experiment if you ask people to judge
the tilt of a grain that's right above
this white fixation cross it's hard to
do when it's surrounded by other items
so you can see in the the second panel
here where it says or so those two boxes
to the left and right when you only see
one thing on a screen it's pretty easy
to tell whether or not this thing is
tilted to the left or right but when you
have three things that are bunched
together and you have to judge the
middle one whether it's to the left or
right that's actually pretty hard so
this is a phenomenon called crowning
where to identify something that's
crowded by other objects in your
periphery we know that your sensitivity
and ability to do that kind of tapers
off over time so we've looked at
people's performance on these single and
crowded conditions and we also asked
them to rate confidence in their
responses and what they showed in their
study from Hong Kong University was that
as you might expect shown on the
left-hand slide here people are worse in
the crowded conditions compared to the
single conditions so that's not
surprising but what is surprising is the
fact that your ability for your
confidence judgments to track how
accurate you are is impaired in the
periphery so I have more jargon that I
have to throw at you there is
there is a measure that we use called
the M ratio so what is shown in the dark
gray bars here is a measure of how well
your confidence judgments track whether
or not you're right or wrong so that's
what the dark gray bars showed and if
you are optimal if your confidence
judgments when you're not very confident
are often like wrong but when you're
highly confident you're often right if
you're doing the task optimally that
measure will be right around 1 which is
what you see in the single condition in
the dark gray bars but we know that the
ability of confidence judgments to track
whether or not you're right or wrong
it tapers off in the periphery so you
can see that that measure in the dark
gray bar for the crowded condition is
below 1 so that's interesting your
ability for metacognitive reflection on
what it is that you see in the periphery
is impaired
ok so we've learned things that are
interesting from these psychophysical
investigations psychophysical
investigations indicate that subjects
are more likely to say certain visual
attributes are present in the periphery
even when they're not so you have that
bias towards false alarms that I talked
about you think you see more in the
periphery than what's actually there and
then finally we know that you have
impaired metacognition for crowded items
in the periphery so the periphery is
always cluttered you always have so many
things are off to the side that are
difficult to identify and it's
interesting that your ability to
introspect and reflect on that is
impaired compared to the stuff that you
see when you're directly looking at it
so that's interesting that's work that
we have under review it should come out
in probably a couple months and we're
very curious to hear reactions to that
because I think it's an interesting
finding that again shows us that we
think we see more of the periphery than
we really do so a couple other things I
want to cover I have also been
interested as I mentioned before in
perceptual integration so let's say
you're at a cocktail party and you're
working your way around the room and you
have to try to figure out it can be loud
and it can be crowded when you're in
those noisy environments whatever like
weddings or bars or wherever you're at
you're trying to understand what people
are saying your brain has to do a really
good job in those types of social
situations to figure out who it is that
speaking like
things that you're hearing actually go
with which voices and for those of you
that have experienced in social
situations you know that when you're in
a really crowded bar at a wedding and
you know keeps getting louder and louder
it can be harder to make those
perceptual inferences about how to bind
voices with who is saying what and I've
been interested in that problem as a
neuroscientist but the way I tried to
address integration in controlled
scientific settings is to use simple
settings that test our perception in
space and time so the way these
investigations normally work is that
people in my spatial tasks will try to
localize where I played briefly
presented flashes of light and bursts of
sound so typically these tasks I'll play
simultaneous bursts of sound and flashes
of light and people have to tell me
where both things occurred and we know
based on this effect that's called the
ventriloquist effect that where you
vocalize sounds are often pulled towards
where you see flashes of light so we
know that the way the brain binds thing
in space is it often I there's a degree
to which it's called cue related a cue
Reliability waiting I won't get into
what that term means it's a little too
complex for the time that we have left
but we know that typically your sense of
vision is best in the spatial domain so
where you think you heard things get
pulled towards where you think you saw
things um and in time it's actually the
opposite so if you look at this panel on
the right if you play visual and
auditory things that are separated in
time we know that your sense of hearing
is a little bit better in temporal
perception and your sense of vision so
the way that this typically works in
most circumstances is that your sense of
when you think you saw something can be
modified by when you heard something so
we know that your visual and your
auditory senses interact in different
ways and some very smart people about a
decade ago came up with computational
models to try to account for the
quantitative principles that the brain
might be using to make these judgments
so my work focused on using these models
which I'm showing a graphical
representation of the model here which
says that whenever you encounter
audio-visual sync
your brain has to decide whether or not
those signals label XA and xB come from
the same source and should be integrated
or come from different sources and
should be segregated and the bottom line
is that there are complicated rules and
interesting math that's involved to
account for how we deal with this but my
research was interested on the
perceptual prior that's shown on the
right hand side of this equation we know
you might have heard if you listen to
Anil Seth's TED talk or other perceptual
researchers that perception involves
inference about it's it's essentially
the brain's best guess at what's out in
the world and we can use mathematical
rules like Bayesian statistics to try to
talk about how whatever it is we
experience in a given moment is a
combination of not only what we see but
these pre-existing biases we have to
interpret the world that are called
priors
so one famous prior that you can google
is called the light from above prior if
you look at ambiguously shaded scenes
there are ways that we normally
interpret shading based on this prior
that we have built into our system and I
wanted to investigate this prior for
integration because it seems like this
plays a critical role and how we have
coherent perception of the world so what
I showed through a number of studies was
that these priors are actually stable
over time so people do these tasks that
I just mentioned in different sessions
they tend to have similar values for
this binding prior but these priors tend
to be tasks specific so it's not as
though we have one global prior in the
brain that seems to UM bitties and it
seems to influence how we bind things in
space and time it's more like we have
different priors for different
perceptual tasks that influence how we
perform so shown here is the stability
of that prior but then if you look at
how it generalizes between those two
tasks that I mentioned the temporal task
and spatial task any time it's desist
statistics if you see it a cloud of dots
like that usually you can be pretty sure
that there's no relationship between
those two things
so that's evidence that the the prior is
actually fairly task specific I was also
very interested in whether or not these
priors could change and I
had some results that show that if you
flash things that are far away from one
another in that spatial task over and
over and over again that's shown in the
right hand panel you can actually
increase the prior in people so they
bind more often so that was some work
that I did a couple years ago that
showed that you can increase the spatial
prior I have some modeling results I'm
just showing on this slide that you can
pause and look at later on to show that
you can actually increase this prior in
most subjects going from a pretest to a
post-test phase and then finally we were
interested in whether or not that prior
relates to schizophrenia so if you think
about the symptoms that characterize
schizophrenia one of the things that
characterizes perceptual experience is
the fact that in schizophrenia there's
sort of a disjointed nature people make
impaired have impaired perceptual
inferences and we saw that this binding
prior is at least moderately related to
the number of prodromal features that
call in schizophrenia so for people that
have more abnormal sensory experiences
we show that they're binding prior tends
to be lower so it's an interesting
relationship that we showed but I want
to follow up on that so it's not overly
strong as you can see by the data here
but we think it'd be interesting to try
to see if in clinical patients with
schizophrenia is there actually a
stronger relationship than what we
showed here with people from the general
population so I'm gonna skip my summary
slide here and 36 we have used these
models in many different ways so I can
put up the list of all the publications
of how we've applied Bayesian connell
inference models to different problems I
mentioned an eel sex TED talk so if
you're interested more in perception as
a process of inference to hear more
about that in a way that's accessible
for the general public
I recommend Ulysses and Anil sets TED
talk on well on the 10 website or on
YouTube wherever you can find it and if
you're interested in these publications
of applications of bayesian causal
inference models I have that list right
here but I'd like to wrap up with one
more thing that I've been involved with
today and that
topic that I mentioned before was where
does perceptual content reside in the
brain we've been very interested in this
question as a laboratory and we have
launched a massive neuroimaging project
to try to decode which parts of the
brain are involved in how we perceive
certain categories so in the work that
I've been doing at ATR in the last year
we actually have a database now of more
than 50 subjects where people lie in a
neuro imaging scanner and we show them
3600 images from 40 categories so in
these experiments everyone is lying in
the scanner and they're seeing a
sequence of about one image per second
from each of these 40 categories and
there are 3600 images in total and this
is work that actually was started two to
three years ago from two guys in my
laboratory Vincent a shrewd and Michelle
a fantastic postdoc that I've been
working with he just published an
article in PNAS that relates to the work
I'm going to describe here so you should
google him check out his article and
also we have JD Knotts who's a grad
student in our lab who has other work
that he will be publishing in the coming
year that also stems from this project
and so I wanted to give them credit
before I talk about this because I have
learned a lot from them and they helped
get some of this work off the ground but
as I mentioned before we're really
interested in how these two parts of the
brain which we call DL PFC & VT might
encode these images that people are
seeing which region is really critical
and has encoded the content that people
are seeing there's a lot of debate right
now in the scientific literature about
when we try to decode information from
different regions is that actually just
plain harder to decode from do PFC
because neurons and code things in more
complex ways so there's a great article
up on bio archive by Bhandari and a few
other authors I think David Audrey is
the senior author there and they say
look we know that in neuroscience we've
had success decoding from things like
occipital and ventral temporal areas but
if you look at the results in the
neuroimaging literature decoding from
frontal cortex is flat-out hard but we
have tried to get
this problem of the difficulty of
decoding from PFC by applying what's
called hyper alignment so there's an
effective technique for trying to align
brains across participants to more
effectively read out the content in
different regions and I know I'm running
a little low on time so I won't get into
all of the nitty-gritty details on what
hyper alignment is and how it works but
we have found fairly effective ways to
decode from PFC what I'm showing here
are just some pairwise classification
results for trying to decode whether or
not people saw one category versus
another category so if I want to know at
any given point in time whether or not
someone is seen say a snake versus a
rabbit or a dolphin versus a bat if
those are the two images I'm interested
in I found early on that you could
actually decode with a very high degree
of accuracy from parts of frontal cortex
so these accuracies I'm showing here are
becoming a giant sin in machine learning
they're both training and testing on the
same data set and there are reasons why
I'm showing this finger here for the
project I did and how we build decoders
don't believe that the y-axis on this
slide but know that the content is there
we have done analyses that are much less
sinful and much more correct in terms of
trying to decode information and we saw
early on in this box lock that I'm
showing here that you can decode the
category that people are seeing whether
or not you're decoding from BT those
posterior areas or PFC which is shown on
the right hand slide so early on we saw
that we can decode content for both the
posterior part of the brain and the
frontal part of the brain and I'm very
excited to say that in the last few
weeks I'm just gonna give a teaser here
and I won't actually show the data we
have been able to blow these decoding
accuracies out of the water in both of
these regions using hyper alignment and
trying to come up with better algorithms
to read out the perceptual content so
you can see on this slide from our early
results we can decode above a chance in
PFC and I can
for the last three weeks we are able to
decode with a very high degree of
accuracy from both of these areas using
hyper alignment so I have to end the
main scientific part of this talk with
just a teaser a little bit of data here
and the de teaser we are going to be
talking about these new techniques and
these new results at the assc conference
in poland in the coming year
and I should also be presenting this
later at the Society for Neuroscience
conference in 2018 in San Diego so for
those of you that are skeptical that
prefrontal cortex encodes perceptual
contents we have very interesting
results to show you that go even above
and beyond the data but I'm showing you
today which shows that we can decode
things above chance so there's ways that
we've tried to build on hyper alignment
and deep learning and a number of new
techniques of the field that worked very
well so let's take stock as this come to
a close you have seen today or at least
heard from me and hopefully I've
convinced you that sensory awareness and
your conscious sensory experience
involves confidence decisions
integration content so many different
things that all make up what it means to
have an experience and I think today
we've seen that some of these ideas that
we can dichotomize the brain in certain
ways to talk about where content resides
and we're essentially processes of
report and attention reside that might
be oversimplified things I I'm not
denying that the giant areas in red
shown here in this image are important
for perceptual experience I think
there's a tremendous amount of
scientific evidence that indicates that
yes that is the case but I would argue
that with a number of the findings I
show today and some of the findings that
I referenced as well there is increasing
evidence for a role of frontal cortical
areas in facilitating conscious sensory
experience and for those of you that are
interested I'll close by showing just a
couple images this has been a very
interesting debate we've been involved
with that was published in the Journal
of Neuroscience so if you're interested
you can look up these articles by
Melanie Joly and her co-authors as well
as myself and watch some videos online
of patients that have different types of
brain lesions
so sometimes you can see in patients
really vivid examples of how sensory
experience or function might change
based on where the lesion is so I
recommend checking out our discussions
of not only historical data but also
more contemporary patients and there are
some other pieces of evidence like the
one I'm showing here that if you dig
into that article in the Journal of
Journal neuroscience you might find
helpful so just to conclude today when
you think about what conscious
experience is like one of the metaphors
that people have used in literature is
the Cartesian theatre so it's almost
like when we look out at the world
there's a little man inside our head
that seems to have access to like a
movie screen the way the world is
rendered in front of us and my argument
today would be that when we think about
which parts of the brain facilitate the
content that's on that movie screen when
we look out at the world I know that
posterior areas do play a critical role
in facilitating the content that's on
the screen but I would argue that you
don't get a seat in the kinetic
Cartesian theater unless you have your
frontal lobes working and specifically
the dorsal lateral parts of your frontal
lobe so it's a fun debate that we're
involved in we were using a lot of
paradigms to try to investigate this
topic and I'm excited to see what
results people come up with in the
coming years to try to resolve this
debate about which parts of the brain
are necessary in getting us that seat in
the Cartesian theater so I'll close
today before we turn it over to the Q&A
with just acknowledgments of a number of
people that have helped with this work
in the last five years
thanks to my postdoc advisor Hawk 1-mile
Michele bastos lab facilitated the the
early experiments that I talked about
this presentation Bob Knight was had
great discussions with him about that
Journal of Neuroscience article I
referenced and I probably can't go
through everyone else on this slide in
the way that I should in the time that I
have left but everyone that is listed
here know that I'm extremely thankful
for what it is that you contributed to
all of these projects would not have
been possible without all of their help
including all the names I have wedged in
the lower right hand side of this slide
I did my graduate work at UCLA and a
fantastic army of undergraduates to help
with everything so for even the small
names that are towards the lower right
thank you to all of my undergrads that
help with these projects to all of my
mentors and collaborators listed on the
slide and if you made it this far online
thank you so much for listening as well
so I'll turn it back now over to Tiffany
and hopefully we can have a brief Q&A
before as we wrap things up here so
thanks again to all of you online and
thank you to all of you got lab roots
for organizing this well thank you dr.
Agard for that informative presentation
we will now start the live Q&A portion
of the webinar if you have a question
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the ask a question drop-down
box located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click on the send button we will
answer as many questions as we have time
for today so let's get started with our
first question and this question asks
why would our perceptual systems have a
tendency towards making false alarms in
our periphery for object detection so
this is a great question that normally
when we think about our perceptual
systems we think of these in the context
of evolution right so evolution over a
period of hundreds of thousands if not
millions of years has been sort of
guiding how our perceptual systems work
and typically we think they're going to
be getting better and better at making
use of information in the sensory world
around us
so this experimental evidence that we
have for why we tend to make false
alarms seems counterintuitive you would
think that our perceptual systems would
be close to optimal with how they make
use of information and they're not so
that's a good question at this point all
we can do is speculate but I want to
actually reference a researcher by the
name of Michael Graciano here who
published a piece in the Atlantic
wrestling with why we might see some of
these interesting results when evolution
should have weeded them out and his idea
was there might be times where if we're
trying to survive and
dynamic and changing world that our
perceptual systems might be prone to
sort of have a trigger finger if you
will it might be prone to jump the gun
to try to say that something is there
even when it's not to spur action so
this could occur in the context of like
predator identification so our
perceptual systems might have a bias to
try to think things are out there even
when they're not because that could be
optimal and motivating are either
approach or avoidance of things that
might be dangerous and similarly for
things like like food or mates having a
little bit of a tendency to jump the gun
and think something is there might spur
action in a way that actually could be
optimal to enhance survival rather than
simply remaining stationary until we
have more information so I would say at
this point we're still only speculating
about the evolutionary reasons why that
might be in place but we're going to try
to conduct more experiments or a
laboratory to probe this question more
thoroughly to see how widely this
tendency for false alarms generalizes
across different contexts and as we ask
different types of questions so it's a
good one we have we have ideas for why
evolution might have put that in place
but we need more data before we can say
something conclusive about it excellent
thank you so much for your answer the
next question asks where do perceptual
priors come from and are they
established early in life through
sensory experience driven by genetics or
some combination of the two
another good difficult question and
where there's not a true consensus about
the answer so I mentioned before that
light from above prior and for those of
you that are listening online to this I
actually recommend that you google that
right now and there should be a couple
images that pop up that show you
vivid demonstrations of the light from
above prior and this has been an open
question about why that prior might be
there is it something where when we're
little kids we always experience lights
from above on the ceilings and we know
the Sun is above so maybe we have this
tendency to things light comes from
above just because that's the way it
always happens in our world or other
people think that you
as we have evolved over the course of
you know many many many years maybe
that's actually been built into our
systems inherently to interpret the
perceptual world in this way and I had a
conversation with someone who claims all
references Brian Shaw from Yale
University told me this story about he
was as a graduate student digging in the
library in the stacks one night looking
for another article and he told me he
came across this interesting experiment
where they raised chickens in the 60s
from an environment where the lights
always came from below so someone about
40 or 50 years ago actually tried to
conduct an experiment with baby chicks
and they asked okay if I always raise
animals in a way where the light comes
from the other direction and I show them
these ambiguous stimuli where we usually
see because of the light from above
prior things are indented in certain
ways he said that in this article they
showed that even when the light always
came from below they still seemed to
have a light from above prior so this is
actually one example that it seems as
though even if you change someone's life
experience or you change the life
experience of an animal it still seems
like the light from above prior is still
present so I would love to see that old
study replicated in in some ways because
I think it would be fascinating to have
a more modern data to speak to this
question but I actually come from the
stance of I think it's actually
something that now is built-in in
genetics there's no doubt that priors
can change based on sensory experience
but it's a question to how much they can
change and right now I tend to think
that our perceptual systems tend to have
a way of being wired that lead us
towards these biases but that's another
question where we need more data to
answer it conclusively so but it's a
good one well excellent thank you once
again our last question of the day asks
what our future directions for your
research on prefrontal cortex
now that you have shown shown you can
decode object categories effectively
from using from this area using FM
are I excited about of all of the things
I'm involved with right now in research
there are so many times we debate like
what consciousness is that it's such a
fun topic but it never really feels like
we pin things down conclusively so like
everyone from philosophers to
neuroscientists to laypeople it's such a
cool question about what is
consciousness and now that we have
better techniques in fMRI I really want
to do two things so one is to try to
read out more vivid types of perceptual
content so if you take say the visual
domain and you break it up into things
like hue which is a sort of a synonym
for color or saturation or value you can
google what those being in terms of like
HSV space and I want to see whether or
not we can decode some of those aspects
of experience that we've always
attributed to visual areas so like can
we decode color from prefrontal cortex
can we decode spatial frequency now that
the algorithms are better now that the
decoding techniques are better I want to
show that that information is there so
we've done it with object categories
like I mentioned in my talk I want to
show that we can do it for these other
dimensions and then secondly what I'm
trying to do in some experiments right
now is to use what's called
neurofeedback to change neuro
representations in PFC and I want to see
if that can change your perceptual
experience in a given moment so there
are techniques that we can use now where
you can lie in a scanner and using
neurofeedback I can change patterns of
activity in certain parts of the brain
over time and what I want to demonstrate
is a causal role for being able to
change neural patterns in PFC and have
that directly affect your perceptual
experience in a given moment because I
think what this area is really missing
right now is a conclusive causal
demonstration that if you change
activity in PFC it affects what you see
in any given moment we know from say
surgeries on epileptic patients where if
we insert electrodes into the posterior
areas of their brain and we actually
stimulate those electrodes it can cause
visual
nations so that's really informative and
interesting from a scientific standpoint
because it provides evidence that parts
of posterior areas can actually result
in changing a conscious content that you
experience so there's a great paper in
PNAS by I think it's goin shulk and
Nancy kanwisher where they show that in
epileptic patients if you stimulate
certain posterior areas the people start
hallucinating rainbows and hallucinating
faces in objects and that's a great
demonstration that these areas play
critical roles and what you see in the
given moments and what I would like to
do is to use other neurofeedback
techniques to try to show that if you
change something about neurons with PFC
you're actually modifying the content
because I think in this idea that PFC
plays a critical role in conscious
experience it's those types of
scientific demonstrations that would be
most informative to demonstrate a role
for this area so that's where my
research is going right now in the
coming year and if you keep an eye on my
Google Scholar page or my lab website
I'll updates throughout the coming year
hopefully you can stay abreast of the
new results that I have to see what new
things were coming out with from the lab
excellent well thank you so much I would
like to thank dr. on guard for his
presentation I would also like to thank
leopards for making today's educational
webcast possible before we go I want to
let everyone know that today's webcast
will be available for on-demand viewing
through June of 2018 you will receive an
email from laberd's letting you know
when the webcast will be available for
replay please share this announcement
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you here again soon at lab roots
goodbye